it's hard to believe that it's been 10
years since the first season of True
Detective arguably one of the greatest
detective shows ever made I think human
consciousness is a tragic misstep in
evolution and with seasons 2 and three
not nearly as critically acclaimed as
the first HBO's hoping for a return to
form with everyone's favorite lamb
silencer jod Foster and I got to say we
are off to an amazing start with this
first episode now in this video we're
going to become detectives ourselves
taking a deep dive into every little
clue you might have missed to see if we
can figure out who the killer or killers
are are we actually dealing with some
sort of Supernatural force or is there a
logical explanation we'll explore every
angle and I encourage you if you have
your own theories to leave them in the
comments below finally make sure to like
And subscribe if this video does well
I'll come out with even more True
Detective content let's take a quick
look at this quote here you'll note that
hildred castain isn't a real person
rather a fictional character from Robert
Chambers short story The repairer of
reputations this metaphorical statement
is all about how the Knight can bring
out the worst in people and that even
God cannot control what happens in the
dark fitting for the town of NS Alaska
which can see over a month of complete
darkness from December to January in
fact we open on the last day of sunlight
with this particularly disturbing scene
of reindeer plummeting to their deaths
for no apparent reason the show is
really trying to make us believe that
some sort of Supernatural force is at
play here but what if I told you that's
not the case that every weird thing
we've seen in this episode can be
explained with science yes science these
deers could have been compelled to fly
over this Ridge if there's been a change
in the Earth's magnetic fields something
NASA claims has happened over 180 times
in the last 83 million years we're
actually 200 to 300,000 years due for
one the Earth's magnetic field is what
animals use to navigate during migration
it's how salmon know how to make it back
to their spawning grounds or how geese
know how to go south in the winter this
magnetism could also explain the
interference with the radio and
electricity throughout the episode but
what if it's not magnetism rather
something more nefarious that was
uncovered at the salal research facility
the scientists here have been collecting
ice samples that have been buried for
millions of years with the hopes of
gaining Clues on the origin of Life what
if they unleash something Frozen for
Millennia it's something out of the
movie the thing which is fitting since
there's a thing VHS among their movie
collection the name salow comes from
from a Hebrew word meaning to become
dark fitting since that's what the days
become here it's also a reference to an
Antarctic Island inhabited by
cannibalistic aliens in Edgar alen Poe
The Narrative of Arthur Gordon Pim of
nant Tucket these are tiny Clues we want
to keep in mind as the story progresses
now things seem pretty normal at this
Arctic Base that is until one of the
scientists Raymond Clark arrives
absolutely shaking saying she's a W for
those of you with a good eye you'll
recognize the winter coat he's wearing
ing is the same one detective Liz
Danvers found out belonged to murdered
activist Annie kotto you can barely see
the smiley face patch which was used to
fix the hole in its side how did he come
into possession of this notice also the
snow this guy was recently outside but
who is he referring to when he says
she's awake it's likely any coot talk
since it's believed it's her tongue that
is later found at the base when Annie
was murdered her tongue was ripped out
but Annie's been dead for more than 6
yearsing making this all the more
perplexing side note when Liz
investigates the base she notes that
Raymond Clark was the only person in the
crew to have his own room I also want
you to listen very closely to
this it sounds almost like a radio or TV
abruptly turning off which would align
with the magnetic field theory if these
reindeer were compelled to fly off to
their deaths could the scientists at the
station be compelled to travel off into
the Arctic night without their cell
phones or proper attire 3 days later
detective danverse arrives to
investigate the missing scientists and
it's almost as if everyone here stopped
what they were doing and simply vanished
from the uneaten popcorn and sandwiches
Ferris bu's day off on repeat Le G's
unfinished treadmill run and the wet
laundry in the washer I took a moment to
read some of the salal website pages and
we learned that their main mission is to
quote expand the understanding of the
origins of Life they say this can be
done by sequencing the DNA of cells they
found in the ice and they can po entally
use this sequencing to cure a number of
diseases which could lead to one of the
greatest scientific discoveries of all
time lizz's initial investigation into
the Bas also gives us subtle clues about
our characters that may play into the
broader story starting with Liz she's
forgetful not knowing that her own
glasses are in her coat Hank also tells
his son Peter to speak up around Liz
suggesting lizz's hearing is not that
great speak up Peter I can hear him just
fine Liz has or had a kid the things you
learn when your kid leaves the lunch in
the back seat of the car later in the
episode Liz will have a nightmare in
which a young boy named Holden says the
same line as Raymond Clark she's awake
this is followed by her picking up a
oneeyed polar bear stuffy we'll actually
see a real oneeyed Polar Bear later on
which is accompanied with you guessed it
she's awake back in the city we get our
first look at state trooper Evangeline
Navaro investigating a case of domestic
abuse as we'll see in this episode
Navaro has an obsession with protecting
women and this likely has something to
do with her past with both her mother
and time serving overseas this extends
to her sister Julie who suffers from an
undisclosed mental illness it's implied
that Julie has spent a lot of time in
various Mental Hospitals as she begs her
sister not to be sent to one Julie is
adamant that she is not like their
mother suggesting their mother may have
also suffered from a mental illness one
which negatively affected the family if
you listen carefully you'll hear the
owner of blue King Crab Company tell
Navaro that there haven't been a lot of
crab this year and it's only getting
worse guess what blue king crabs are
migratory animals yet another piece of
evidence which backs this magnetic field
Theory but the most mysterious of all
the characters introduced this episode
has to be Rose agono she seems to be
this loner living on the outskirts of
town and the first time we see her she's
gutting a wolf that's got to be some
sort of symbolism well she's visited by
a vision of a man named Travis Travis
according to Navaro is dead now right
before Rose sees Travis that weird radio
manipulation sound is heard suggesting
that this is all in Rose's head I'm
inclined to believe that whatever
compelled the scientists to leave their
base is the same thing that compels Rose
to follow Travis in fact whatever power
this is May manifest in different people
in different ways Navaro believes that
there is some connection between the
Cold Case of Annie Kay and the missing
cellow scientists before moving to the
state troopers she was a detective
working on this particularly brutal case
she states that whoever killed Annie
must have really hated her stabbing her
over 30 times with a star-shaped weapon
cutting out her tongue and forensic
stating that her body was kicked after
she was already dead Annie was hated by
a lot of people in town due to her
opposition of a local mine a mine which
is the lifeblood of the town as Annie's
brother says you kill the M you kill
Anis so there could be a lot of people
with the motive to kill her I want us to
keep in the back of our minds the name
Kate mckitrick she's only mentioned once
in this episode but Annie was known for
showing up to Kate's house to quote
demand answers so something is
definitely going on here Navaro would be
kicked off Annie's case we both know
what really happened we aren't exactly
sure what this was but this prompted
Navaro to be transferred to the state
troopers so this will undoubtedly be
explored in future episodes there's also
something really confusing about lizz's
attachment to the case on the one hand
she tells Navaro to let it go because
the killer will never be found but on
the other she's still actively exploring
the case even going so far as to get
detective Pete to steal his father's
files on nek why continue on with the
investigation if you truly believe the
killer will never be found now this is
also another big mystery why is Officer
Hank so hesitant to give up these files
according to Hank there was some sort of
flood at the department and the files
were brought to his place a flood would
definitely be a convenient thing to
happen if you wanted some damning
evidence to be destroyed Liz is called
by a concerned Mother after Leah has
found making a pornographic video with
This Woman's 15-year-old daughter or 16
as Leah States we know that Leah isn't
lizz's biological daughter but the two
live together and Liv seems to be this
mother-like figure to her it also begs
the question is there or was there a man
in lizz's life we do know she had a son
and Navaro even hints that Liz might
have had a connection with someone on
the force how's daddy Conley pointing at
a picture of her and another man when
Liz and Leah are almost hit by drunk
driver Stacy Chalmers Liz has a quick
flashback of her as a child stepping on
broken glass it makes me wonder if a
drunk driver killed someone close to her
in her past which would explain why
she's particularly harsh against
Stacy Peter here has a son named Darwin
with his wife Kayla Darwin is a fitting
Choice considering Charles Darwin in his
theory of evolution it is evolution or
where life came from that the scientists
at salal have come to study as a side
note Peter tells Liz that sala's funding
comes from an NGO and contributor but
he's cut off by a drunk Stacy Chalmer
before we ever get to hear who this
mysterious funer is the only other big
player that we've been introduced to so
far is the mining company Peter is also
having to deal with his father's new
fiance a male order bride from Russia
something Hank prepares for by
repainting his home Darwin has drawn
This creepy picture of a local Legend in
case you thought this show hasn't lean
too heavily into the supernatural I
think that this is a misdirect one of
the weirdest scenes in this episode is
Navarro's relationship with Havoc she
basically uses him for sex and I found
it a bit uncomfortable that during the
deed he tells her to wait but she keeps
on going and don't get me started on the
toothbrush Liz continues to investigate
the murder of Annie Kay finding the coat
from one of Annie's arrest photos is the
same as the one worned by Raymond Clark
at the salal station so she trecks back
there looking for any more clues and to
her surprise Navaro is also there
meanwhile Rose continues to follow
Travis who does this weird dance almost
as if he's channeling something for a
brief moment we can even see this
flicker in his eye although I can't be
100% sure this isn't a reflection of
rose's flashlight regardless I still
don't believe Travis is an actual dead
body leading Rose along rather that this
is something in Rose's mind Liz's search
does not turn up Raymond or Annie's
Parker and both she and novaro get in a
fight over whose fault it was that Annie
killer was never caught at the end of
the day Navaro is shut down because she
was the one in charge and she failed to
solve it it's for this very reason this
case still haunts her the episode ends
with Liz and Navaro being called out to
what Rose discovered in the frozen
tundra three bodies encased in ice
looking as though they've been frozen in
place I'm assuming that these are three
of the scientists but I wasn't able to
100% confirm considering the state of
their bodies and what little time we
actually saw of the scientists at the
beginning but there are sever several
interesting things to note here first
these guys are buried deep within the
snow check out the chainsaw here in the
background which has barely made any
Dent into the ice it takes a while for
this kind of stuff to build up and since
it's only been about 3 or 4 days since
they went missing I doubt that's enough
time for them to get buried all the way
up here second they appear as though
they've been frozen in time look at the
Petrified looks on their faces holding
their hands in front of them as if to
defend themselves these aren't people
who have slowly succumbed to the cold
weather granted if they they are seeing
visions it's possible they could freeze
in that position additionally we don't
know if they were killed here or killed
somewhere else and then brought here we
have to keep all our options open third
it looks as though they are naked or at
least missing several articles of
clothing we can see this guy's bare
shoulder thus the episode ends with far
more questions than it answers but now
we move on to our trailer sleuthing
section where we take a look at the
season's trailers for Clues on what
could happen next keep in mind I won't
be covering every clip only the ones I
think are relevant to the story it looks
like we're going to get a flashback of
when Liz and Navaro work together on a
case we can see Navaro has her APF
police uniform on here and it seems they
were a little bit too late to stop this
man and a dead woman in front of them
did Navaro make a mistake that resulted
in them not reaching her in time the
frozen bodies appear to have been
branded with a swirl mark on their
foreheads a mark Navaro says she's seen
years ago on a case she worked Liz and
Navaro team up for this case and it
looks as though they bring the frozen
bodies to a local hockey arena for
further EX examination with Liz
concluding these men died before they
froze and that their injuries may have
been self-inflicted we get this shot of
someone wearing Annie and Raymond's
Parker and that sure doesn't look like
Raymond jwes has some sort of mental
break and it looks as though Navaro has
to put her in hospital the one thing she
told Jules she wasn't going to do it
looks as though we'll also get a
flashback of Annie protesting the silver
sky mine this sign over here stating
protect our water really stuck out to me
considering Ryan said the water hasn't
been drinkable for three days maybe the
mine is trying to cover something up and
with the scientists researching ice
maybe there's some sort of connection
with the water here's a shot of someone
disposing of a dead body so likely no
Supernatural monster killing all these
people however we do get this spooky
shot of the woman who looks a lot like
the one found dead in the home Liz in
Navaro discovered I'm guessing this is a
nightmare dream or some kind of vision
and not an actual monster also this does
not look good at all here we get a shot
of who Navaro called daddy Connelly he's
telling Liz to get her under
control either this is a flashback and
he was her former boss or he's somewhere
higher up in the chain of command and
comes to check in on what the hell is
going on in NIS it also looks like we'll
get more flashbacks from Navarro's time
in the military and also a flashback of
Liz and her son Holden with Holden not
around I'm sad to think of what happened
to him nvar will get dragged by this guy
at their research station is this
Raymond Clark it's hard to tell Navaro
gets the upper hand however and has him
tied to a chair if you look really
closely you'll see someone else by the
the doorway perhaps Liz Liz here doing
some sort of recorded interview similar
to detectives rust and Marty in season 1
I'm wondering if she's responding to a
past case or the one we're watching
right now so that leaves us with episode
one I don't know about you guys but this
first episode was very promising but
what did you think I want to hear your
thoughts and theories on the season in
the comments below thanks for watching
Remember to like And subscribe and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram @ thinkstory YT
until next time remember Daddy loves you
very
much